the cat is out of the bag when it comes
to uh Henry Cavill coming into the mix
how much did you have to do with that
mister and what do you know about Man of
Steel 2. we've established Black Adam as
the most powerful and Unstoppable force
on our planet where's the most
Unstoppable force in the universe where
is he because we've all been fighting
for this moment so I will say this
welcome home
uh you just dropped me on
I can tell you that uh the whole goal
and initiative of Black Adam was to
build out the DC Universe by introducing
not only Black Adam but the entire JSA
five
five superhero characters new new
superhero characters in one movie and
also as I have been saying all along
um
there's an ethos that we at seven bucks
have seven bucks Productions myself my
co-founder Danny Garcia and Hiram Garcia
and that is we always put the fans first
audience comes first
tonight is the night and look at him
he's got a bit of a superhero showdown
at the box office this weekend he is
going up against Batman and George
Clooney with Julia Roberts in take it to
Paradise so how is this showdown going
down at the box office listen let me
tell you something George Clooney can't
be messed with
um
Julia Roberts can't be messed with
either but the pairing of them two
together are strong but there can only
be one Black Adam what was your girl's
reaction to seeing you in Black Adam's
costume they absolutely love it and I
got little ones they're six and four and
even though I can't show them the entire
movie I'm going to show them some of it
they just know that something special is
happening yeah and daddy like this is
like in our family and there's Black
Adam everywhere you turn in our
household so I can't wait to show them
foreign